Tom Cruise as was Hasty Pudding man of
the year back in 1994
now he's back at work on the new Mission
Impossible movie after of course that
crazy stunt that went wrong Nancy and
dramatic new footage reveals just how
bad that accident really was I knew
instantly was broke and I I knew I broke
it
showing the disastrous stunt the broke
his ankle in August from three different
angles crews told the BBC's Graham
Norton that he gave the bad news to the
crew I said sorry guys it's broken you
know technically hospital it's broken
every that's a rat production was halted
for nearly two months and tom says he
spent eight to ten hours a day seven
days a week in rehab but he's back at
work again posting pics of new stunts
from the set on instagram this one from
today with safety cables presumably
airbrushed out got almost sixty thousand
likes in the first hour
hard to believe by looking at these pics
that tom's ankle still is broken mean
it's not fully healed before shooting if
we have a release date so we gotta keep
going
that includes pushing himself to do this
full thirty second long sprint on a
London rooftop and there's more tom says
the new film will include his largest
action stunt ever we're told it took two
years to plan let's go that's saying
something considering the harrowing
action we've seen out of crews in the
first five mi movies
ironically Tom told Carly back in July
that he'd never been hurt on a movie
I've never broken anything on a film
I've never missed a day of work making
these movies
I guess Tom didn't knock on wood because
this is what happened just two weeks
later here's the thing even though Tom's
injury delayed production first seven
weeks Mission Impossible fallout is
still expected to meet its original
release date it will hit theaters July
27
[Music]
you